la venganza es poco estas son algunas de
las palabras que envió a alexander
doguín a través de sangrado un medio que
apoya a vladimir putin y que es dirigido
por su amigo cercano el magnate
konstantín malo fe
nuestros corazones anhelan algo más que
venganza o retribución solo necesitamos
nuestra victoria
mi hija sacrifico su joven vida en el
altar de la victoria así que por favor
ganen su hija daria dubina murió el 21
de agosto cuando el vehículo en el que
viajaba explotó a las afueras de moscú
el ideólogo culpa a ucrania y el
servicio federal de seguridad que es el
igual del fbi de rusia sostiene que la
presunta responsable del ataque es
natalia box una ucraniana nacida de 1979
y que siguió a domina durante largo
tiempo el fsb sostiene que ella
pertenece al regimiento a su este grupo
lo niega tu discurso el informe dice
unidad militar 30 57 que incluye un
destacamento separado de la fuerza de
operaciones especiales a soft pero no
todos los que sirven en la unidad
militar 30 y 57 son soldados de azov y
esta mujer no es soldado del regimiento
ni tampoco sofá y no es novedoso que lo
inculpe a los ucranianos sus ideas
fueron usadas por putin para justificar
la invasión rusa pues aquel
ultranacionalista sostiene que ucrania
a misiones territoriales son una amenaza
para eurasia y es que quien propone que
europa y asia deberían estar unidas en
un gran imperio gobernado por los rusos
y sin la ideología comunista su obra más
reconocida los fundamentos de la
geopolítica traza las líneas de como
rusia puede restaurar su poder como
viendo por ejemplo las divisiones dentro
de eeuu y las ideas independentistas en
reino unido- esos planteamientos lo han
convertido en un referente de las ideas
de ultraderecha en europa